-Hey, Sean. Welcome to the show.
How are you?
-Very well. How are you?
-I'm doing very good.
There are reports that you
recently got married.
Is this true?
Congratulations!
[ Chuckles ]
How recent is it?
-It's, um, Thursday.
-Oh, my goodness.
So this is, uh -- you're reall
fresh into it.
-Yeah, we did a COVID wedding.
By that, I mean it was
a county commissioner on Zoo
and we were at the house,
my two children and her brother.
And we did it that way.
-Actually having had
a very large wedding,
that actually sounds pretty nice
and low stress.
-Let's say there are sociall
liberating factors under COVID
-[ Laughs ]
I want to compliment you on what
I feel was the finest moment
in television this year.
You played yourself
in an episode
of "Curb Your Enthusiasm"
as the owner of a pet store.
And it's the hardest I laughed
all year.
Did you enjoy that?
-I did enjoy it, yeah.
I'm a big fan of that show
so it was nice to get
the invitation to come down.
They have a pretty loose
play plan,
very encouraging,
and we had a lot of fun, yeah.
-Does all the time you're
spending here take away from
you know, acting?
-I was never a very Zen
sort of personality.
but I find myself very,
very calm now.
I think, you know,
it's the birds.
[ Toucan screeches ]
Shut up!
[ Toucan squawks ]
-Yeah, I asked Larry David
about it,
and he said you improvised
yelling at the parrots,
and I thought, well,
that was the best moment,
so, again, I tip my cap.
-Thanks.
I can't remember what was
improvised and what was not,
because we just did it
a few times
and they kind of loosened it u
each time.
And, yeah.
But I had a good time doing it
Short, you know?
It's just, uh,
shot one morning and, yeah
-It's very nice when you -
when you create a world
for someone to come in,
work a very short amount of time
and score.
That's why you keep gettin
people to say yes to you.
-Yeah.
They figured out that chemistry.
They've got -- so you go i
there, you kind of feel like
there is some unseen
safety net anyway
because everybody's terrific
on that show all the time.
So, you figure, well, I don'
want to be the odd one out
-[ Laughs ] Right? Exactly
I want to talk about CORE.
So this is an organization
you started
after the earthquake in Haiti.
And now you're also using it
to help increase COVID testing
what brought you to
the decision to do that,
and was it easy to take
an organization that had bee
set up for other things
and to sort of shift it
into this testing world?
-Yes, and no.
I mean, what was easy was to say
we had more than most
in terms of the infrastructure
of a disaster response
organization.
And we had done infectious
disease once
with the cholera outbreak
in Haiti.
That's, you know, a bit of
a starter kit
for what this incredibly
transmittable COVID is.
So we initially went to
the governor of California
and said,
"Look, we've got people.
We've got some experience,
and we've got the will to play
Where would you guide us?"
He guided us to Mayor Garcetti
in Los Angeles city
and Los Angeles Fire Department,
where they had already set u
test sites, but they were --
those test sites were bein
operated by firefighters
who, frankly, had other things
to be doing for the city.
And so we were able to tak
training and to absorb
those sites and then expan
site after site,
until now we're doing
all the city sites.
-You know, one of the majo
issues has been a lack
of transparency from the
government to the people
insofar as what -- how long it's
going to take your results
what it means you need to do i
the time between when you ge
tests and you get your results
Is it important when you'r
testing people to let them kno
exactly how long it's going to
be until they find out?
-I think it's essential.
And this is something
that we've been working
very hard with the city on
and in the --
and that's just in
our operations in Los Angeles.
Because, you know, we're
throughout the country.
And we've been expanding thi
with a criteria
for our organization to operate.
Our criteria is moving towards
a total five-day program.
So you are notified --
from the time you test,
you come in with the assumptio
that you will cooperate
in contact tracing,
you will isolate from the time
you're tested,
certainly to the time
you are notified.
If you're notified positive,
you will continue to quarantine,
and you'll be contact traced
all within five days.
After five days, any of thes
reports that you hear,
if it is more than five days
the cat's out of the bag.
It becomes relatively useless,
except for those who
by being notified
begin to quarantine
from additional spread
with the community or family
But it's under a -- where
you have an open economy,
very difficult to get people who
are out of a job a long time to,
if they are asymptomatic,
quarantine themselves
out of a job.
So it has to be --
the language, at least,
has to be charged with
the seriousness of the pandemic.
It is not always enforceable
but it is always mandatory
And that's what
we're moving toward,
but we want people to know tha
from the time they're tested
they will only have two days
of full isolation
if they then test negative
-And do you find, like,
when you explain it
to people in sort of terms
that are easy to understan
like that, that they're pretty
game to go along with the rule
you set out?
-Yes.
I think that it is less an issue
of rebellion against the
machine or against liberty
than it is an issue
of chaotic communications
from the White House down.
And also, through a lot of -
While a lot of the media's
done a very good job,
if half of the media
is not doing a good job,
if they're going point to poin
every day, you lose track
of the five,
six essential things
you've got to know.
And it's those essential thing
you got to demand
of your friends and neighbor
and of the public health system.
-This is very exciting as well
I know you're doing
a reunion table read
of "Fast Times
at Ridgemont High"
coming up in a couple of weeks
right?
-Right.
Yeah, August 20th, I think
-That is such an iconic role
but is it true that
you did not feel as though
you nailed that audition?
-Oh, for the original movie?
-Yeah.
No, I have to say that
that movie's audition
gets more attention
and questions,
but it is true that I never di
a good audition for anything
I was just not a good --
-Okay.
-The big difference with tha
one was after I failed
the audition,
the casting director,
Don Phillips, came running after
me in the parking lot,
I guess having seen something,
and drew me in to give it
a little bit more.
I was resentful of --
of auditions and just felt
if they didn't get it
by osmosis,
I shouldn't give it till
they were paying me.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, as you've also been
on the other side,
you've been a director.
Do you feel as the directo
when people come and audition,
you have a great empathy for
what they're going through
-Yeah. And many times
I won't audition people.
I'll often sort of just
have somebody come in
and meet and get a sense of them
and talk to them a little bit,
their instincts about the
character and the story.
And, you know, there's bee
times where I've gone and cast
non-actors without
auditioning them.
And other times you feel you
have to, 'cause you're looking
for some kind of a chemistry
with somebody.
You got to see that or --
but, yeah, I'm very empathetic
I find it painful.
-Yes.
I've been very happy that
the last decade or so
of my life, I haven't had
to go through that,
because it is --
it is heartbreaking.
-It's the only good thing
about success in acting,
frankly, is not auditioning.
-Does that mean that --
I know you've directed
Jack Nicholson twice.
is it safe to assume that
he did not have to auditio
for either of those?
-Surprisingly, he did not
have to audition.
He just had to respond
to my pleas.
-In the days when
I was struggling at "SNL,"
I never quite found like
I had my footing.
I wasn't particularly good
at impressions,
but I did do a Sean Penn
impression back in the day
and, uh, we've never met.
This is the first time
we've interacted,
and you're much better humored
than I feel like I portrayed you
on the show, so I feel lik
I owe you an apology.
-No, I reject that apology
I saw exactly myself
at many chapters of life.
It was -- it's a zone I get in
It's not that I don't find
the moment funny.
I think I actually sometimes -
There's a kind of adrenaline
in following
one's own self-seriousness
that I guess is a certain,
I don't know, counterpoint
that I get quite a kick out of
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, that's good.
It's good to know that there's
a kick getting
getting passed along
in the viewing of it.
Hey, thanks so much not just
for making the time for us
today, but with everything
you're doing with CORE.
We really appreciate it.
-Thank you very much.